these diamonds are like blinding et
special correspondent Sharon Osbourne
sat down with Mariah Carey on Monday in
Las Vegas she's back at Caesar's Palace
with her number 1 to infinity residency
that continues through the summer Vegas
baby and you know what's the best thing
about being here the fans that come from
all different places in the world
her fans love her and so does her fiance
billionaire businessman James Packer the
couple got engaged in January so do you
think that you've got time this year to
actually do that I mean that's the goal
I wasn't like on the prowl like what are
we doing you know I mean it's just you
meet people and then it was nice what
are you doing what you do and he does
what he does is he gonna wear the
trousers oh darling how can you ask me
that question of course he'll wear his
trousers and I'll wear whatever one song
I'm going to wear Mariah's twins
Moroccan and Monroe are now five years
old and she opened up about raising them
in the spotlight such a different world
for me now but they're like growing up
in they're actually you know they have
strong personalities
they're pretty mean look out they make
me laugh and frustrate me sometimes they
give it they they're tough they're not
easy but they're great so Monroe is like
this incredibly she's a great ear so she
can repeat what I sing to her and Iraqi
it's not the same type of ear but he's
like growing into it and he's just a
superstar anyway like he's just a dove
country's a comedian he's freaking
hilarious up next for me me her a
docu-series Mariah's world which airs
later this year if the most important
event that's ever happened so just how
real is Mariah keeping it when was the
last time you went grocery shopping
Truth grocery shopping it's very bad
lighting in the Christmas
have you not noticed it's fluorescent
lighting tell me you go to the grocery
store exactly